Elon Musk says he is for free speech one
of the realities about being for free
speech
is that you have to be for free speech
or for speech that sometimes might cause
uncomfortable consequences this is the
reality for so-called Free Speech
absolutists we are now learning that
Elon Musk limited Tweets in Turkey
during the tight presidential election
in which president erdogan on Sunday
failed to get to the 50 threshold and
now as a result that election will go to
a runoff is it Twitter's right
to restrict access to whatever they want
sure
no one's denying that what we're talking
about is the selective application of
so-called Free Speech absolutism from
self-proclaimed Free Speech Heroes like
Elon Musk